president Trump has come out and said
that his family will have no role in the
next Administration do you want Jared
and Ivanka to serve in a second
Administration no I tell I said that's
enough for the family you know why it's
too painful for the family my family's
been through hell
I mean they Eric my son is a fine boy
you know him very well he's a fine young
man
good student good everything comes in
we're doing beautifully then I decide to
run for president I mean I don't think
anybody in the world in history has ever
had more subpoena sent to him nobody has
been through what my family has been
through very simple and so that means
the family is not going to be involved
this time this might help Trump
politically because I think a lot of
people even Arden Trump supporters don't
like how involved his family was I don't
know all of Trump's family I've met some
of them the ones that I've met and
talked to I I like I think probably this
is a net political benefit the downside
is that this is an admission that
personnel has been a weak point for
Trump